[Musique]
salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
vous avez vu où je me trouve dans un
endroit exceptionnel je suis au Palais
Garnier
[Musique]
bon je vous avoue que je connais un peu
les lieux c'est ici que nous avons
tourné la vidéo pour célébrer le million
d'abonnés de la chaîne Epicure en même
temps je suis à peine rassuré on raconte
que les lieux seraient hantés par un
fantôme le fantôme de l'opéra alors
existe-t-il vraiment toujours est-il
qu'il insaloge ici allez suivez-moi on
part à sa recherche
[Musique]
ce personnage enterrait les sous-sols de
l'Opéra et seraient à l'origine de
plusieurs drames
c'est l'écrivain français Gaston Leroux
qui le rend populaire il apparaît pour
la première fois en 1909 dans un
feuilleton publié dans le journal Le
Gaulois puis un an plus tard
devient le héros d'un roman le succès
est-elle qu'il sera adapté dans le monde
entier 21 pièces de théâtre lui seront
consacrés cette film et 16 comédie
musicale
il se passe des choses bizarres ici
mais s'agit-il d'une invention et bien
pas si sûr car l'écrivain s'inspire de
fait bien réel des événements troublants
qui vont semer le dos le 28 octobre 1873
un terrible incendie se déclare non par
au Palais Garnier mais au Conservatoire
de musique de la rue le Peltier qui se
situait tout près d'ici le bâtiment est
entièrement détruit et l'incendie fait
de nombreuses victimes
Ernest un jeune pianiste prometteur et
grièvement brûlé au visage totalement
défiguré il se serait réfugié dans les
souterrains du Palais Garnier alors en
construction avant de disparaître sans
laisser de trace la légende raconte
qu'il y aurait achevé la marche nuptiale
qu'il est en train de composer pour sa
fiancée morte dans l'incendie et avec
laquelle il devait se marier quelques
jours plus tard fou de chagrin le jeune
homme aurait enté les lieux de cette
fille déchirants voilà qui fait
forcément penser à Eric Le Fantôme
imaginé par Gaston Leroux lui aussi est
musicien lui aussi vit dans les
souterrains et lui aussi est défiguré
pour dissimuler son visage il porte
toujours un masque noir dans le roman
blanc au cinéma pour contraster à
l'image
Eric
[Musique]
avec ce premier drame la légende du
Fantôme de l'Opéra étant marche
désormais chaque nouvelle événement
inexpliqué lui est attribué c'est le cas
lorsque le cadavre d'un machiniste est
retrouvé sous l'opéra ou bien lorsque la
chanteuse suédoise Christine hamilson
jure avoir entendu une voix mélodiuse
l'appelée durant la nuit elle affirme
même avoir déjà perçu plusieurs fois un
homme mystérieux dans sa loge cet ange
de la musique comme elle l'appelle
portait une cape noire et un masque sur
le visage on retrouve ces événements
inexplicables dans le roman de Gaston
Leroux mais le drame le plus saisissant
s'est déroulé dans cette salle le 20 mai
ce soir là en pleine représentation un
contrepoid de 700 kg servant à maintenir
l'énorme lustres tombent suite à la
rupture d'un câble il s'écrase sur la
tête d'une spectatrice madame Chaumette
qui meurt sur le c'est la stupeur une
enquête est aussitôt diligente elle
révèle sans le moindre doute qu'un
incendie est à l'origine de la
catastrophe mais cette explication ne
satisfait pas tout le monde beaucoup
sont persuadés que c'est un coup du
fantôme preuve de ce qu'ils avancent la
victime était assise dans un fauteuil
pourtant un numéro maudit
le numéro 13
Gaston Leroux n'hésite pas à reprendre
cet événement dans son roman son fantôme
menace même de faire tomber à nouveau le
lustre si le directeur de l'Opéra ne lui
verse pas la somme de 20000 francs par
mois
son fantôme et met l'argent et c'est
toujours sur la 13e marche du grand
escalier qu'en 1932 un petit rat du
ballet aurait atterri après une terrible
chute selon la légende un éclat toujours
visible sur la marche d'après de
l'accident
[Musique]
décidément le nombre 13 ne porte pas
champs au Palais Garnier à tel point
qu'il n'existe pas de loge d'artistes
portant ce numéro en revanche dans la
grande salle une loge spectateur suscite
la tension de tous la loge numéro 5
[Musique]
c'est la loge du Fantôme de l'Opéra
c'est écrit dessus ici la fiction
rattrape la réalité malgré sa position
idéale pour profiter du spectacle aucun
spectateur dit-on ne s'y aventure jamais
contente allez
[Musique]
dans le roman cette loge est toujours
réservée mais elle n'est jamais occupée
sauf peut-être par le fantôme voilà de
quoi entretenir le mystère d'autant que
la malédiction du Fantôme de l'Opéra
semble se poursuivre aujourd'hui à
Broadway en 1986 en pleine
représentation de la comédie musicale
consacrée aux fantômes un grand
chandelier se brise et manque de blessés
des spectateurs on passe à deux doigts
de la catastrophe le 25 septembre 2016
c'est à Paris au Théâtre Mogador qu'un
incendie se déclare juste avant la toute
première représentation le spectacle est
reporté et finalement il n'aura jamais
lieu est-ce le dernier coup du célèbre
Fantôme de l'Opéra
rien n'est moins sûr mais cette histoire
continue de passionner de nombreuses
personnes aujourd'hui encore tenez en
2018 un escape game a même été organisé
dans les couloirs du Palais Garnier le
but était de débusquer le célèbre
fantôme les participants ont-ils trouvé
[Musique]
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout c'est vraiment le meilleur
soutien que vous pouvez apporter à la
chaîne j'espère qu'elle vous a donné
envie de lire le roman de Gaston Leroux
et de venir au Palais Garnier pour le
visiter ou assister à une représentation
qui sait vous y croiserez peut-être le
fantôme de l'opéra en attendant
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu et
à vous abonner à la chaîne pour
rejoindre la grande famille des
épicurieuses et des épicurieux à bientôt
[Applaudissements]